[Applaudissements]
vous savez tous ce que veut dire faire
le plein il faut dire que c'est facile
il suffit d'aller à la pompe à la
condition évidemment que la pompe où
l'on va ne soit pas une pompe à vide
mais de faire le plein plutôt faire le
vide qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce
que c'est le contraire de faire le plein
c'est à dire roubles et jusqu'à ce que
la jauge du réservoir indique que le
réservoir est vide on devine que faire
le vide c'est quand même un peu plus
compliqué c'est un peu plus utile que
simplement tombé en panne sèche
alors d'abord qu'est ce que le vide
un rapide coup d'oeil dans un
dictionnaire laisse perplexe parce qu'il
fait voir qu'il ya plusieurs sortes de
vide
par exemple le vide qu'on peut faire
avec une pompe à vide n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec le néant hindouiste ni
avec la vacuité bouddhiste ni avec le
vide que je pourrais faire autour de moi
on a le bon cigare dans une pièce ni
avec le vide vertigineux qui est frêle
acrophobes et qui exit l'alpiniste et
donc par un effet ironie qui se pourrait
que le move it soit victime d'un trop
plein de significations et donc il faut
préciser ce qu'on entend par ce mot ait
procédé à ce que paul valéry appelez un
nettoyage de la situation verbal la joie
que j'ai oublié les guillemets dont je
recommence il faut procéder
je voulais guillemets un nettoyage de la
situation verbal je fermais guillet pour
parler comme paul valéry comme ça on est
tranquille
l'idée de vivre elle évoque d'abord
l'absence de toute chose le rien le
néant qui sont trois mots presque
synonyme c'est-à-dire qu'ils disent à
peu près la même chose cette idée de
vide
à ce propos vous avez remarqué une chose
étonnante sexy ont dit ces trois mots
l'un derrière l'autre en les faisant
précéder par le pronom jeu ça donne ceci
je n'ai en vide rien je n'ai envie de
rien alors 7
cette bizarrerie de nous est guère même
elle nous égare parce que faire le vide
ce n'est pas la même chose que d'abord
envie de rien puisque pour faire le vide
faut déjà avoir envie de faire le vide
ce n'est pas non plus faire le néant
c'est à dire rasé l'univers vous rester
modeste ce n'est pas non plus ne rien
faire ce n'est pas être fainéant et donc
même si l'idée de vide évoque une
présence raréfier jusqu'à l'absence le
vide c'est pas la même chose que le
néant et c'est tant mieux pour moi qui
vous en parle parce que l'idée de néant
si on y réfléchit un peu c'est une idée
indicible impensable parce qu'en fait
c'est une idée qui est destructrice
d'elle-même
dès qu'on se met à imaginer ou à penser
le néant on en fait quelque chose que
précisément il ne peut pas être dès que
l'idée de naissance forge dans notre
esprit le mouvement même de notre pensée
transforme le néant en question une
sorte de substance à laquelle on va
attribuer une spatialité une matérialité
que le nez on ne pourrait posséder sans
contredire sa propre définition est donc
un paradoxe penser le rien n'est jamais
pensé à rien l'idée donné en est une
matière à penser que si on n'y pense pas
puisque il devient une sorte de matière
qui détruit les mêmes données ans qu'il
est dès qu'on y pense
alors si loving n'est pas le néant
qu'est-il un autre des définitions par
exemple vite c'est ce qui reste dans un
récipient après qu'on en a tout enlevé
donc le vif ce serait le lieu de la
béance radicale de la vacuité absolue
sauf que cette définition pose un
problème parce que si le vide n'est pas
rien c'est qu'il ait quelque chose
quelque chose de particulier et
curieusement ce quelque chose de
particulier ne doit être ne doit pas
être retiré lorsqu'on fait le vide sinon
le vide en question devient un pur néant
qui ne peut pas être puisqu'on a dit
qu'il était quelque chose donc
donc pour faire le vide
il faut absolument tout enlever
absolument tout sauf le vide
ça fait combien trois minutes que je
parle
et on n'a pas beaucoup avancé on tourne
en rond j'ai même l'impression d'être
une cruche d'avoir l'air d'une cruche
même ce qui est un sentiment assez
désagréable mais que je peut interrompre
en me rappelant que la cruche
c'est justement l'exemple choisi des
cartes pour parler du vide si je prends
une cruche je peux retirer l'eau qu'elle
contient alors elle contient de l'air
garde une cruche
l'ère de la cruche je peux le pomper à
ce moment là il reste dans la cruche le
rayonnement électromagnétique émis par
ces parois jeu peut l'annuler en portant
la température de la cruche au zéro
absolu
on cite je peux retirer la cruche il va
rester un lieu une portion des espaces
est-ce que je dois retirer aussi
l'espace où dois-je interrompre
l'entreprise d'exfiltration que je viens
de commencer
où s'arrête la liste des objets que je
dois au thé pour faire le vide
poser cette question c'est comprendre
que le tout dans la phrase le vide c'est
ce qui reste quand on a tout enlevé
dépend de la théorie physique que je
choisis comme référence c'est à partir
des objets qu'elle considère comme réel
que je pourrais en notant en éliminant
ces objets définir tel ou tel type de
ville par exemple si on prend la
physique de newton celle qu'on apprend
au lycée pour cette physique il ya trois
sortes d'objets dans l'univers il ya
l'espace ya le temps il ya les corps
matériel à faire le vide s'est retiré
tous les corps matériel et alors il
reste l'espace vide c'est-à-dire sans
rien nada l'intérieur qui passe son
temps à rester lui-même est égal à lui
même très bien sauf que la physique
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui pour décrire
la matière c'est pas du tout celle de
newton
c'est une autre physique qu'on appelle
la physique quantique en physique
quantique quand on retire les particules
toutes les particules on obtient un vide
qui n'est pas l'espace vide
c'est un vide qui contient de la matière
fatigué c'est d'ailleurs des particules
qui sont bel et bien là mais qui
n'existe pas vraiment ce dont les sorte
de fantôme auquel il manque de l'énergie
de sorte qu'elles ne peuvent pas se
matérialiser et elles deviennent
inobservable ce qu'on appelle des
particules virtuelles et l s'ébroue dans
ce vide façon un peu végétative comme
des belle au bois dormant
comment faire pour la réveiller mais il
faut leur donner un baiser énergétique
c'est-à-dire leur donner les méga
électron volt qui manque à leur pleine
l'incarnation
pour ce faire c'est très simple on fait
des collisions de particules de haute
énergie et ses particules se comportent
comme des princes charmants
microscopiques
ils donnent leur énergie au vide
quantique du coup des particules
virtuelles aval cette énergie deviennent
réelles et sorte de vide avec une
énergie qui peut être très longue
elle qui faisait une longue pièce depuis
les débuts de l'univers retrouve la
vitalité qu'elle avait autrefois et
quitte ce repère avec une énergie
colossale
lorsque je vous dis là du vide quantique
ça fait penser à une intuition ainsi
génial quelle blaise pascal philosophe
mathématicien physicien death pascal
intuition qu'il a formulées dans une
lettre en fait 147 lettre qu'il a
adressée au père noël
alors c'est pas le père noël des sapins
c'est le révérend père noël qui était un
jésuite auteur d'un livre intitulé le
plein du vide avec lequel évidemment
blaise pascal n'était pas d'accord
et dans cette lettre blaise pascal écrit
ceci il y à autant de différence entre
le néant et l'espace vide qu entre
l'espace vide et la matière le l'espace
vie dit il tient le milieu entre le
néant et la matière autrement dit le
statut qu'elle est vide quantique c'est
exactement le statut que blaise pascal
attribué au vite tout court
c'est une sorte de prologue de la
matière d'état de référence de plus
basse énergie tout émerge la matière
tels que le telle que nous la
connaissons sans qu'elles coupent jamais
son cordon ombilical la matière reste
reliée au vide d'où elle est sortie
alors la physique quantique c'est
évidemment très compliqué mais en gros
on peut dire c'est une physique qui
décrit toutes les manifestations du
monde physique comme des excitations à
partir de cette étape fondamentale de la
matière à partir de ce vide quantique
qui est une sorte de diapason primitif
de l'univers alors si je vous dis cela
c'est tout simplement parce que le fait
que le vide quantique à rebours du sens
des mots soient plaints peut nous
inspirer
c'est à dire que c'est une métaphore qui
nous permet de penser que finalement
faire le vide
c'est d'une certaine façon faire le
plein puisque le vide et plein mais
alors le plein de quoi je prendrais
l'analogue quantique passé le plein de
désirs d'énergie c'est le plein dans vie
de fougue
c'est le plein de libido existentielle
c'est le plein d'événements de soi dans
la grande vivacité et donc mon conseil
est le suivant la prochaine fois que
vous aurez un coup de pompe que vous
vous sentirez plaint de troubles un
aller faire un tour par la pensée dans
cette source d'élan vital qu'est le vide
quantique et vous verrez que passer par
ce vide là c'est tout le contraire d'un
passage à vide
l'épreuve du manque du repli sur soi du
calme que ce vide nous impose nous en
fait ressortir plus vivant plus délirant
plus fin moins banal et donc
positivement dopé moi je vous laisse
réfléchir là dessus
en espérant n'avoir pas parlé dans le
vide
et surtout en vous souhaitant bon
courage pour cette petite méditation
fisico philosophique que je vous propose
aux vertus potentiellement stupéfiante
[Applaudissements]